votre pays le danemark on le disait été
pionnier du pass sanitaires et la mise
en place dès le mois d'avril mais vient
de le suspendre d'ailleurs puisque on
considère qu'on en a plus besoin ça vous
comment vous faites exactement au
danemark qu'est ce que vous avez fait de
spécial pour ne plus en avoir besoin on
avait mis en place des mesures
extraordinaires pour une crise sanitaire
extraordinaire et des cons on a
maintenant au niveau des infections qui
se baisse et aussi en à un niveau des
vaccinations qui est très très haut on
est plus que 70% de la population qui
est vacciné maintenant vaccine les
enfants jusqu'à
12 ans peut-être même moins donc les
enfants de l'école on a dit qu'on en
retire ses mesures extraordinaires qui
est donné des droits des compétences au
gouvernement qui sont extraordinaires
qui a eu en limite temporelle et donc on
a arrêté avec les dès l'expiration de
passer à 8 heures aux entrées
[Musique]